good morning um listen we've spent the
last two days now reporting on this
tragic death of a new york city police
officer and it seems like everyone
understands the gravity of what happened
and now now we're looking at the
juxtapose this to an another uh you know
border patrol agent or ice agent being
killed in the line of duty and i feel
like people just expect that they don't
understand how how tragic this is what's
happening on our border every single day
um you know just speak to us about how
dangerous this job is and why it's so
important um to reevaluate what we're
doing down there
well look
prayer is out to special agent solace
and his family it's always tragic
to lose one of the finest but look
i've said it many times before
people want to beat up on president
trump that his immigration policy is
inhumane let me be clear when president
trump pushed illegal immigration to a
35-40 year low depending what month to
look at illegal immigration down eight
it was down 83 percent
that saves lives because the most
vulnerable people will not make that
journey if they know they won't succeed
and joe biden comes in office destroys
all his policies and what's the result
under president trump last year there
was a total 254 migrants died crossing
that border their first year under
president biden that is more than
doubled to 557 that's 119 increase and
that doesn't count the hundreds that
died traveling to mexico or the hunters
that died going through the daring gap
in panama add to that over a hundred
thousand overdose deaths most of it from
fentanyl that the dea says come across
the border add to that 59 cbp officers
who died from covet because joe biden is
ignoring title 42 when it comes to
hundreds of thousands of children and
family groups that come across with
covid that affects these agents so let
me tell you something joe biden's
policies are not humane it's killing
people at a huge rate more than i've
ever seen in my career
you know
vice president kamala harris has a trip
to honduras to uh you know solve the
root problems
at the border crisis in the marine corps
we have these life-saving steps it's
start the breeding stop the bleeding
treat the wound treat for shock doesn't
it seem in a juxtaposition here that we
should maybe treat the border before we
start talking about oh let's go to
honduras and make their life better and
and fix the root cause don't we need to
kind of stop the bleeding and start the
breeding for the breathing first here
absolutely you gotta plug that damn and
you're right joey look i've done this
for 35 years we have given central
america and mexico billions of dollars
we've tried this before president trump
tried it look this is the
if you want to find the root causes of
what's happening right now all she needs
to do is walk down the hall to the
biden's office their policies has caused
this surge if you look at what president
trump did
it the data speaks for itself trump's
policies worked it saved lives illegal
immigration down 83 percent
so she wants to find the root causes
just go to the oval office and you can
walk over to the secretary dhs alejandro
mayorka's office their policies have
created this surge and that's a dead
stop
director tom holman thank you so much
for joining us today and let's just hope
that our border uh finds some sort of of
sanity soon and and things like this
tragedy quit happening
i agree 100 percent
thank you